hi there steve kaufman
today i want to talk about reading the
importance of reading and just how
powerful it is
as a way of learning languages as a way
of learning about things in general
reading is tremendously powerful
now there are people who say
you know i don't like to read
i like to watch movies
and i have never considered watching
movies
as a great way to learn languages
to me watching movies is either a reward
for having learned the language
or um a stimulus
so i'll give you two examples
my wife likes to watch these
different language
movies and series on netflix
and so she got us
watching this thing called gran hotel
grand hotel which is a spanish series
and i'll now be sort of addicted to it
we watch it every night
but it's in spanish and so it's
tremendously enjoyable for me to watch
this movie and understand the spanish
that's a reward
uh if movies come on television at home
and typically in canada they're in the
original version if it's in german if
it's in chinese if it's in japanese it's
tremendously rewarding to be able to
watch the movie in the language
um
so uh but it's also a stimulus when i
started with russian i remember watching
this movie jestoki romance which was a
uh
story out of the 19th century
it's actually a play
called
without a dowry
by um ostrowski but it was so romantic
it was so out of the 19th century russia
far away wow you know i want to learn
that language so movies you know it's
fun it stimulates you it's a reward but
it's i can't learn from that i i learn
so much more from reading and of course
from listening because i read i can just
i'm sitting on a plane i open a book i'm
uh you know there are so many situations
and the words then you know reading is
so word rich you have to connect
words to meaning there's no picture
there's nothing to explain
or to show you what's happening you have
to be able to imagine that from the
words so to me reading is is
tremendously powerful that's why with my
arabic for example
you know i could have decided to go with
a phonetic script and try to get to
where i can say some things right away
hello how are you what's your name
and i can't do that in russian excuse me
in arabic but i am determined to become
a reader of arabic because
reading is a way that i can continue to
improve my knowledge
in the language
i can read online i can import things
into link and read
whereas my ability to find people to
speak to in arabic is going to be
limited so reading to me is is extremely
important and i'm always willing to
invest the time and i also recommend to
people invest the time
uh
in learning the script whether it be the
cyrillic alphabet for russian or
ukrainian
or uh you know chinese characters or or
you know the japanese you know hiragana
or hangul
uh or the greek or whatever it might be
in arabic i want to learn the script so
that i can read so that i will have this
ability at any time
to pick up something and read it and be
constantly improving in the language now
some people say well i can read but i
can't speak well you know to speak you
have to speak so at some point you have
to speak and you have to speak a lot but
many of the people who have said to me
you know i can read but i have trouble
speaking in fact they don't read very
much so i say well what do you read in
english like i've seen this with
immigrants they say well you know i can
read that's not my problem i can't speak
and i say what do you read
for example have you ever read a novel
in english have you read a novel from
you know the the beginning to the end
no
okay so if you read the odd newspaper
article that's not really reading i want
to get to where i have read novels in
polish in russian
i haven't yet done so in greek i never
reached that level but i want to get to
that level i want to get to uh you know
on our link count 30 40
50 000 known word level so that i can
pick up books and read them from cover
to cover because that is really going to
bring the language
into me
now there are people who say
i'm elitist
uh you know
because lots of people learn languages
and can't read you know
you know
illiterate societies where people speak
two or three or four languages well sure
that's true
um
of course that's true
there was a period
when we had no writing i mean homer
the great
you know
barred writer of ulis you know the
odyssey and uh
you know the battle of troy and all this
kind of stuff
the iliad
uh in those days we had this wonderful
oral tradition the great
um
you know ramayana
uh um stories in in
southeast asia and so forth these are
all oral traditions yeah but in the
meantime we invented writing
uh writing is a way of recording
speech just like a
tape recorder or an mp3 player records
speech so we use these uh
recording devices in order to carry
sound with us listening is very powerful
by the same token we have developed
writing so why wouldn't we use it why
would we say no no i don't want to read
i just want to rely on
on you know hearing it
again people do what they want to do but
to me
reading and stephen crash is very strong
on this he feels that
if we just allowed and encourage people
to read kids in school they would learn
better their language skills would
improve more
than any deliberate instruction and
explanation of grammar and so forth and
so on because we can consume so much
uh
by by reading and this is all training
our brain in the language whether it be
our own language i mean obviously
those people who express themselves the
best in their own language are typically
people who read a lot if you want to
improve your ability to express yourself
to write
if you want to write better you have to
read more and read material that is well
written so
reading is tremendously convenient it's
a powerful way
to learn and we have to train ourselves
and and you know obviously like if i
watch the uh spanish movie and my wife
likes to have the english subtitles on i
have no trouble following the english
subtitles
even in span if they had spanish
subtitles which would be better in my
opinion from a language learning
perspective i would be able to keep up
because it's the same script however if
i wanted if i watch a chinese movie and
they have chinese subtitles i have real
trouble keeping up uh similarly with
cyrillic or any uh you know writing
system that we have had less exposure to
so the key there is the more you expose
yourself to a writing system the more
you train the brain in reading the
better you're going to read there's a
constant gradual
not noticeable but nevertheless gradual
improvement so my advice to people is in
all of your various language learning
activities make sure you do enough
reading it's a very powerful way to
improve in any language
and uh some people may want to spend
their time watching tv and and listening
to music i don't think in the long run
that's going to take you as far as
committing to doing a lot of reading bye
for now
[Music]
you